schön dass sie dabei sind meine damen
und herren wobei wir uns nicht ganz
sicher waren sage ich ihnen ehrlich ob
man diese woche überhaupt senden soll
denn ja die schnittmenge aus
nachrichtenlage und comedy geht aktuell
natürlich gegen null immerhin einiges
macht noch ein bisschen hoffnung zum
beispiel wie sich fast die ganze welt
mit der ukraine gegen putin
solidarisiert
also jetzt mal abgesehen von
bedeutungslosen zwergstaaten wie eritrea
oder china die schweiz friert jetzt das
vermögen von putins oligarchen ein die
schweiz die war sogar im zweiten
weltkrieg neutral in der un
vollversammlung haben gerade 141 staaten
putins krieg verurteilt was
zugegebenermaßen den ukrainern in ihrem
verzweifelten kampf nicht direkt hilft
aber es ist wenigstens ein signal an
diese wirklich unfassbar tapferen
menschen die ihr blockiert eine gruppe
ukrainischer männer ihre dorfstraße auf
der ein russischer panzer auf sie
zurollt und tatsächlich der panzer hat
anscheinend immer wieder versuchen
offenbar ukrainische zivilisten
russische militärfahrzeuge aufzuhalten
ihr wird jetzt kein bier mehr abgefüllt
stattdessen werden molotow-cocktails
gebaut auf einem der etiketten steht
putin der pimmel this russian schätz kam
hieß es
molotow cocktails meiner oma
kohlrouladen gemacht wenn besuch kam
aber den hatte sie meistens auch
eingeladen das ist der unterschied
ukraine mehrbett es geht gar nicht klar
viel spricht leider dafür dass die am
ende keine chance haben gegen putins
riesige militärmaschine auf eine art hat
die botox fresse mit dem großmarkt
komplex trotzdem schon verloren da steht
man dieses brutalen überfalls auf ein
friedliches nachbarland wird er nie
wieder los egal wie das ganze ausgeht
und im fernduell mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky da zieht er sowieso
den kürzeren er hält eisern die stellung
und haut wirklich nur noch sätze für die
ewigkeit raus ein angebot der amerikaner
in der sicherheit zu bringen hat sie
lenski angeblich mit den worten
abgelehnt er brauche munition keine
mitfahrgelegenheit
wirklich wo auch ihn hat wladimir putin
offenbar sträflich unterschätzt
ausgerechnet ein gelernter komiker zeigt
der welt mal eben wie mut geht während
der kriegsverbrecher putin darauf
beharrt die ukraine zu befreien obwohl
seine raketen in dicht besiedelte städte
fliegen wovon genau werden die ukraine
so befreit ja putin von ihren häusern
der beschießt atomkraftwerke angeblich
ist er ja inzwischen völlig isoliert und
trifft nur noch eine handvoll
hofschranzen und ja sager wie hier als
er an einem seiner riesen tische zwei
generälen erklärt sie müssten jetzt die
atomstreitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft
versetzen und selbst die gucken als
hätte der chef inzwischen nicht mehr
alle raketen im silo
ist putin noch ganz dicht das ist gerade
so was wir die frage aller fragen in
meine klar im lock down sind ja viele
verrückt geworden nena der wendler warum
ich der vladimir das ist eher ein alter
gekränkte skrupelloser man das
irrational handeln eines 59 für apps
gibt's da noch fragmente von von von
rationalität immer wieder kommt es zu
ungewöhnlichen wutausbrüchen hat bei
vielen die frage aufgeworfen ob der
russische präsident überhaupt noch bei
sinnen es dazu müsste man putins kopf
rein gucken und ehrlicherweise da möchte
ich gar nicht reingucken ine ich auch
nicht ehrlich gesagt eine ziemlich
müßige diskussion
entweder ist ein psychopath mit
atomwaffen ganz blöde kombination oder
ein land hungriger das boot mit
atomwaffen beides nicht gut was
allerdings für die play theorie spricht
putin hatte wohl ernsthaft erwartet die
ukraine würden seine soldaten mit blumen
und schnittchen empfangen ein schneller
sieg war fest eingeplant und das kann
man leicht erklären denn putin ist es
gewohnt dass man ihn gewinnen lässt sein
team legenden des eishockey gewann das
spiel anschließend 14 zu 7 dabei schoss
putin selbst acht tore laut kreml
angaben sogar 9 die verteidigungsarbeit
seiner gegenspieler war allerdings auch
durchaus übersichtlich wie in der
wiederholung unschwer zu erkennen ja ich
würde auch jeden puck durch lassen wenn
ich sonst im arbeitslager lande und
deshalb ganz wichtig liebe eltern ihr
kind nie beim uno spielen gewinnen
lassen sonst wird das später diktator
derweil läuft die propagandamaschine
natürlich auf hochtouren der krieg darf
zum beispiel in russischen medien gar
nicht krieg genannt werden es handelt
sich um eine spezialoperation zur
friedenssicherung
logisch ach ja und die gewählte
regierung in kiew ist ein
marionettenregime der usa bestehend aus
zitat putin drogensüchtigen und nazis
ernsthaft wer glaubt so was
das ist gar kein krieg das ist eine
sonder militäroperationen gegen nazis
die macht denn der ukraine ergriffen
haben präsident wäre aber der präsident
ist jude wie kann er gleichzeitig nazi
sein
wir leben in erstaunlichen zeit
nazi juden was es nicht alles gibt
übrigens und das kann man gar nicht oft
genug sagen russen nicht gleich putin
immer mehr fallen auf seine lügen eben
nicht mehr rein schämen sich für den
krieg oder lassen sich sogar bei demos
verhaften auch deren mut macht hoffnung
in diesen düsteren tagen und noch was
hier ja unfassbares ist gerade passiert
meine damen und herren haben sie das
eigentlich mitgekriegt
europa hat sich schneller fast geeinigt
hammer die europäische union die seit
2005 10 ununterbrochen über das thema
flüchtlinge streitet hat sich innerhalb
von tagen beim thema flüchtlinge
geeinigt diesmal stimmt scheinbar der
kulturkreis es schade ist so schade dass
erst einer mit atomkrieg drohen muss
damit brüssel mal aus dem quark kommt
oder ja auch in sachen sanktionen sieben
russische banken werden vom
zahlungssystem swift ausgeschlossen sehr
gut okay wir kaufen weiter russisches
gas und finanzieren damit immer noch
putins krieg aber
hey dafür darf russland nicht mal beim
eurovision song contest mitmachen ist
das eigene strafe
wir deutschen müssen uns dabei plötzlich
mit hässlichen themen wie rüstung oder
abschreckung beschäftigen weil wir davon
aber gar keine ahnung haben sitzt jetzt
in jeder sondersendung zur ukraine
achten sie bitte darauf immer ein
pensionierter deutscher general ja immer
also mir ein aktiver immer nur
pensionierte egal wo du rein selbst
rüstige senioren erklären das
kriegshandwerk ehrlich ich wusste gar
nicht dass wir so viele rentner im
generalsrang haben wahnsinn aber gut
wenn alle das machen haben wir als
mainstream sendung ab sofort natürlich
auch immer ein im studio sitzen es ist
ja klar hallo putins angriff verläuft
sondern förmlich über drei haupt
stoßrichtungen er ist aber
offensichtlich überrascht von der
residenz des gegners erzielt wenig
raumgewinn und macht taktische fehler
vor allem auf der operativen ebene
und das bedeutet weiß ich nicht darf ich
jetzt wieder ins heim die schließen um
mitternacht die tür ab nein tatsächlich
meine damen und herren erleben wir eine
historische zäsur letzten sonntag von
olaf scholz im bundestag verkündet
deutschland liefert jetzt doch waffen in
ukraine gibt demnächst mehr als zwei
prozent vom bruttoinlandsprodukt für
verteidigung aus und die bundeswehr
krieg noch 100 milliarden und ob
geschenkt wo hat der stolz denn die
kohle plötzlich aufgetrieben das sind
detailfragen entscheidend ist eine neue
zeit bricht an kurz und knapp erklärt
von gernot hassknecht
gernot hassknecht erklärt deutschlands
neueste 180 grad kehrtwende in weniger
als 180 sekunden
guck mal an plötzlich zauber der große
scholz ini 100 milliarden aus dem hut
warum genau 100 kann keiner erklären ist
einfach ne coole zahl und jetzt raten
sie doch mal wer von dieser summe erst
in urlaubs rede am sonntag erfahren hat
na wir
die grünen
grünen linken aber eingeweiht fritz märz
wohl auch der hausmeister vom bundestag
nur den grünen hat keiner erzählt klar
jeder wünscht sich zur abwechslung mal
bundeswehr mit fliegenden flugzeugen und
schwimmenden schiffen trotzdem kurze
frage sollte man die bundeswehr also die
effektivste deutsche geld
verbrennungsmaschine nicht erst mal
reformieren bevor man ihr frisches geld
zum verbrennen gibt aktueller wie etwa
knapp 50 milliarden und dafür kriegt man
dann so was hier flugzeuge der
bundeswehr haben in den vergangenen 20
jahren mehrere hundert mal während des
flugs teile verloren super dann können
sie ja jetzt für 100 milliarden neue
schrauben zum runter schmeißen kaufen
aber wie gesagt es sei ihnen gegönnt 100
milliarden
sogenanntes sondervermögen
klingt einfach geiler als schulden mit
unseren neuen spendierhosen müssen wir
dann aber auch die ganzen anderen
baustellen angehen
digitalisierung bildung oder und jetzt
fange ich wirklich an zu träumen
funktionierende schultoiletten von denen
man ohne cholera wieder zurückkommt sehr
gut
also gerade mal ein verfügtes 112 vom
bundeswehr sondervermögen können wir
allen deutschen schulen für den pandemie
herbstluft verschenken
was ich damit sagen will der eltern auf
jetzt geht es los für die fdp kann ich
sagen dass wir die schuldenbremse im
nächsten jahr einhalten also nächstes
jahr gibt es nichts mehr verstehe dann
gehe ich mal lieber sofort zur sparkasse
und hole mir meinen sondervermögen für
koks und [ __ ]
gernot hassknecht ja immer diese extreme
jahre lang waren wir viel zu naiv
gegenüber putin jetzt stürzen wir uns
quasi nahtlos in eine neue
rüstungsspirale
deutschland will also viel mehr für die
bundeswehr aus geben das hat der kanzler
persönlich versprochen habe es gerade
gehört bundeswehr ist noch ein begriff
oder das sind die typen die in den
letzten zwei jahren hauptsächlich für
das gesundheitsamt die rachenabstriche
gemacht haben hatten wir ursprünglich
mal für was ganz anderes angeschafft und
dann irgendwie das interesse verloren
jetzt ist es wieder erwacht und zwar in
gestalt von 100 milliarden die
bundeswehr soll jetzt 100 milliarden
zusätzliches geld bekommen woher kommt
denn das geld
das kommt von ihnen
erfrischend ehrlich und war
staatsschulden gehören immer allen da
ist der staat durchaus großzügig so weit
gehört die bundeswehr wurde wohl über
jahre tatsächlich kaputt gespart und
zwar wie immer an der falschen stelle
ich gebe nun mal ein paar beispiele die
deutsche flugabwehr ich dachte die wie
wichtig die flugabwehr haben sie als
truppengattung 2012 praktisch
abgeschafft die marineflieger de facto
aufgelöst es fehlt ohne ende munition
und sonstige ausrüstung weshalb wir wenn
die nato wie gerade ihre ostflanke
stärkt gerade mal 100 mann in die
slowakei schicken können eine kompanie
mehr geht nicht da drängt sich eine
unbequeme frage auf das will ja keiner
hoffen und das steht aktuell natürlich
auch nicht zur debatte das tatsächlich
die bundeswehr dieses land deutschland
heiligen muss wäre sie dazu in der lage
aktuell
ja prima hätten wir das auch geklärt
laut grundgesetz haben wir die
bundeswehr eigentlich überhaupt nur für
landesverteidigung und ausgerechnet das
kann sich aktuell mieten die
hubschrauber vom adac damit ihre piloten
auf ihre flugstunden kommen der
bundeswehr fehlt warme unterwäsche um
himmels willen viele soldaten tragen bei
übungen wie dieser ihre eigenen
wintersachen auch das walkie talkie ist
privat das einzige vom gerät ist seit
monaten kaputt natürlich das kann doch
alles bitte nicht mehr wahr sein freunde
weißt du was ich rufe mal selber im
verteidigungsministerium an und
beschwere mich gibt es doch gar nicht
hallo frau lamprecht schon wieder kein
netz die bundeswehr lässt zurzeit in
frankreich
analoge funk geräte aus den 80er
nachbauen ist jetzt ausdrücklich kein
witz
600 millionen euro für veraltete
funktechnik weil unsere truppe mit der
digitalisierung nicht hinterherkommt
aber so läuft das halt beim bundes alles
kommt später wird dafür aber viel teurer
als olaf scholz die 100 milliarden
verkündet hat ist der aktienkurs des
rüstungskonzerns rheinmetall übrigens
direkt um 40 prozent nach oben
geschossen hier welt exklusive aufnahmen
direkt aus dem rheinmetall aufsichtsrat
während der scholz rede ja ich glaube
die fans gut
ankommt wenn man sein könnten das
eigentliche problem der bundeswehr ist
nicht geldmangel sondern eine behörde
das bundesamt für ausrüstung
informationstechnik und nutzung der
bundeswehr in koblenz also unser
beschaffungsamt wirklich so etwas wie
die mutter aller bürokratie albträume
ausschreibungen dauern viel zu lange man
lässt sich regelmäßig von der industrie
über den tisch ziehen hunderte
dienststellen sind bei denen unbesetzt
seit sieben jahren versuchen sie zum
beispiel rechtssicher ein neues
sturmgewehr zu bestellen klappt aber
nicht heißt im ernstfall käme wieder das
g36 zum einsatz eine knarre aus den
frühen neunzigern mein gott ja
vielleicht sollte man die koblenzer
bruder einfach ganz zu sperren und alles
nur noch bei amazon bestellen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten erwarten
jedenfalls völlig zu recht dass
dass dieser staat ihnen den rücken
stärkt dass sie eine regierung haben die
ihnen mehr gibt als nur sonntags ein
paar warme ganz genau genug der warten
wolle jetzt müssen endlich mal fahrten
folgen so sieht's doch auch kleiner fun
fact unter annegret kramp karrenbauer
und ursula von der leyen hat das
angeblich so klamme
verteidigungsministerium unfassbar viel
geld für externe berater ausgegeben und
zwar fast so viel wie alle anderen
deutschen ministerien zusammen gerechnet
und dann kommt so was dabei raus doch
absurd kennen sie das auch ihre kaputte
bundeswehr wird von einem haufen
windiger berater auf vordermann gebracht
und sie haben null ahnung was die typen
machen für den aus voll geld ich habe
null ahnung was youtube machen für den
arsch voll geld dann buchen sie jetzt
unser anti consulting consulting eine
ganze armada von weiteren bwl schwer
lappen berät sie wie sie schon ganz bald
mit viel weniger beratern auskommen für
ein paar hundert millionen euro
garantieren wir komplett sinnlose
powerpoint-präsentationen die absolut
nichts bedeuten und unbequeme wahrheiten
die ihnen noch keiner geschafft hat
jetzt weiß ich wo das ganze geld
geblieben ist wir haben viel zu viele
berater
gemein rechnung
das anti consulting consulting
unsere berater beraten sie gerne ob die
beratung gegen sie viel beratung für
seehofer bekommt
guter rat ist teuer und schlechter eben
auch wie wir beim bund lernen aber jetzt
wird alles gut denn die bundeswehr krieg
frisches geld und sogar über eine
rückkehr der wehrpflicht bzw der
allgemeinen dienstpflicht wird
diskutiert übrigens exakt 40 jahre nach
nicoles grand prix sieg mit ein bisschen
frieden schlimmes lied wichtiger text
und am tag des deutschen esc
vorentscheid schalten wir deshalb mal
kurz live rüber in die ralph siegel
mehrzweckhalle in köln porz zum kollegen
friedemann weise
genau 40 jahre ein bisschen frieden und
leider so aktuell wie lange nicht mehr
in dem song geht es ja um die angst vor
einem atomkrieg eine angst die jetzt
plötzlich zurück ist das komische ist
damals haben die leute ganz andere
konsequenzen gefordert abrüstung zum
beispiel unfassbar frieden schaffen ohne
waffen haben die grünen gefordert heute
wäre das mit denen grund für den
rausschmiss zeitenwandel 100 milliarden
sondervermögen ich habe das mal
ausgerechnet das ist für jeden soldaten
über eine halbe millionen euro am besten
direkt als zalando gutschein dafür
sollte man schon ein paar warme socken
kriegen und jetzt kommt vielleicht dann
auch die wehrpflicht zurück kämen die
jungen leute gar nicht mehr früher
mussten alle männer mit 18 zur musterung
da musste man dann die hose ausziehen
und ein fremder mann hat hier ohne zu
fragen an die hoden gefasst und gesagt
wussten sie mal heute unvorstellbar ohne
maske ich glaube wegen dieser hohen
übung gab es damals auch noch keine
frauen bei der truppe was sollten die
stattdessen machen ließen sie mal ich
selbst hat natürlich den wehrdienst
verweigert und dachte damit gehörig
automatisch zu den guten kann man heute
keinem mehr erzählen aber immerhin habe
ich als zivi gelernt gitarre zu spielen
wenn auch nur zum playback
[Musik]
wir waren viel zu lange viel zu nahe wir
wollten den frieden aber ohne den krieg
wir glaubten an worte aber nicht an
beschuss doch damit ist jetzt endlich
schluss
die rüstungskonzerne haben wir
kritisiert doch unsere meinung jetzt
revidiert stell dir vor es ist krieg und
kein panzer es da darum fordern wir mehr
ein bisschen mehr geld für warme mützen
für die soldaten die uns beschützen ein
bisschen mehr geld für munition und zwei
waffen an unseren drohnen ein bisschen
mehr geld 100 milliarden das können wir
doch dann beim klima sparen was bringt
uns windkraft denn wir bedroht sind die
zahlen noch ändern
denn alle
1100 milliarden
1000 milliarden
wehrpflicht ab sieben jahren
raketenwerfer und
handgranaten für alle einen schönen
mehr
si
ein klar
[Musik]
deuce
august
[Musik]
ein bisschen friedemann weise doch genug
von der waldreichen bundeswehr reden wir
mal über menschen denen es gerade nicht
so gut geht über gerd schröder zum
beispiel ja der hat zwar gerade den
einmarsch in die ukraine bei linkedin
sagen wir mal kritisiert ohne allerdings
seinen kumpel putin zu erwähnen könnte
mit den rund 800.000 euro zu tun haben
die ja jedes jahr in diversen
aufsichtsgremien russischer
staatskonzerne verdient ist aber nur
eine theorie denn ich meine klar sonst
hat er ja nur die ex-kanzler rente im
büro ne handvoll mitarbeiter wie viel
lauter da altkanzler schröder verliert
laut medienberichten alle vier
mitarbeiter in seinem bundestagsbüro
darunter auch seinen langjährigen
redenschreiber und büroleiter
sämtliche mitarbeiter in schröders büro
haben gerade gekündigt in sack gehauen
vor lauter fremdscham jetzt muss das
zuständige kanzleramt neue auftreiben
und bezahlen von unserem geld borussia
dortmund hat ihm die ehrenmitgliedschaft
entzogen und auch die spd quält nur noch
eine frage wohin mit opa der
parteivorsitzende lars klingbeil
distanziert sich öffentlich und sehr
deutlich olaf scholz sagt ich kenne man
gar nicht und all das passt scheinbar
komplett ab am gerd ganz deutschland
fragt sich wie bringt man diesen
geldgeilen man dazu seine posten in
putins aufsichtsräten zu kündigen ganz
einfach mit noch mehr geld und zwar vom
fernsehen vergessen sie diese
ochsenknechts freuen sie sich auf die
neue mega peinliche dokusoap diese
schröder kims hannovers power couple
hautnah und ungeschminkt folge eins wert
allein im büro nachdem seine mitarbeiter
gekündigt haben muss der schönste
kanzler aller zeiten seine
autogrammkarten selber unterschreiben
was für eine demütigung folge 2 der typ
die russische hymne
gänsehaut und das emotionalste
staffelfinale wird besucht sein
heimatdorf ich war mal hier von paar
jahren da wohnten noch die polnischen
es gibt sie noch
menschen
mit
65 staaten
elisabeth ja auch schon tot ach das
alles bei diese schröder games auf rtl
drei dem sender für leute denen rtl 2 zu
intellektuell ist
ja holt bestimmt gute quoten wenn alle
ex frauen von schröder das gucken das
läppert sich im übrigen längst schröder
natürlich ganz wunderbar davon ab dass
sich auch andere spd promis nicht gerade
mit ruhm bekleckert haben in den letzten
wochen der fraktionschef rolf mützenich
zum beispiel der kurz vor einer
öffentlich den ukrainischen botschafter
melnik angepackt hat warum melnik hatte
sich erdreistet kanzler scholz zu bieten
beim besuch in moskau ultimativ den
abzug von putins truppen zu fordern
jetzt frisst mütze natürlich kreide
genau wie konsolen schwesig jahre lang
für nord stream zwei gekämpft hat und
sich bei twitter raus redet mit dem
grandiosen satz ich habe niemals ein
gespräch mit putin geführt ach so dann
konnte sie ja gar nicht wissen dass das
ein böser mann ist in meck-pomm gibt es
ja kein internet peinlicher ist
wahrscheinlich nur noch das ehepaar
wagenknecht der oscar und die sarah
lafontaine hat noch vor zwei wochen
behauptete die usa hätten in der ukraine
einen umsturz finanziert was eins zu
eins putins propaganda entspricht quasi
grimms märchen und frau wagenknecht gibt
sich nach dem einmarsch bei youtube fast
schon nachdenklich wie konnte aus jenem
putin der einst im bundestag geredet hat
der dem westen umarmt hat die hand
ausgestreckt hat zur zusammenarbeit wie
konnte aus jenem mann der putin werden
der jetzt wild um sich schlägt ja wie
konnte aus diesem süßen kuschelbären mit
der knuffigen kgb vergangenheit so ein
fieser map werden gut georgien damals
tschetschenien bomben auf syrische
krankenhäuser klar aber sonst ihre
sympathische drei sekunden später war im
selben wagenknecht video schon wieder
die nato schuld am krieg dabei ist ja
nicht in die ukraine einmarschiert aus
angst vor der nato sondern aus angst vor
der ansteckenden demokratie im
nachbarland ist echt preisverdächtig was
die frau so raushaut
der deutsche comedypreis 20 22 in der
kategorie präzise vorhersage des jahres
geht an sahra wagenknecht ich meine
russland das ist ja relativ deutlich
haben faktisch kein interesse daran in
der ukraine einzumarschieren natürlich
nicht natürlich nicht der deutsche
comedypreis lachen bis der russe kommt
sahra wagenknecht zuletzt offen
kritisiert von gregor gysi und dann gibt
es natürlich noch die traditionellen
putin verstehe auf der anderen seite des
politischen spektrums
sie wissen schon die alternative für
russland alice weidl und timo grub anna
leenen sanktionen ab und fordern
stattdessen müsse putin zitat endlich
glaubwürdige angebote machen ja ich
finde auch das hat er verdient oder nach
allem was er für die welt getan hat in
letzter zeit gut frau weiter kritisiert
wenigstens den völkerrechtswidrigen
angriff und das ist in der afg nicht
selbstverständlich ich sag nur krim
annexion das völkerrecht ist das eine
traditionen historisches bewusstsein
kultureller hintergrund sind das andere
und dann muss man irgendwann auch mal
das völkerrecht
das völkerrecht sein lassen da eben
völkerrecht ist ja eher so ein
unverbindlicher vorschlag rechte putin
fans tatsächlich ein globales phänomen
auch bei der sogenannten old white
bewegungen also den neuen rechten in den
usa gibt es glühende anhänger die seen
wladimir putin sogar als verbündeten in
dem kampf der ihnen wirklich wichtig ist
gerade erst offen ausgesprochen beim
fifa-kongress dem jahrestreffen der
ultra-konservativen
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine nicht
schön aber wer stoppt endlich die
schlimme wagnis invasion diese
geisteskranke frage stellen sich neue
rechte auf der ganzen welt so auch
dennis knossalla der in deutschland
gerade den entsprechenden verein
gegründet hat das ist korrekt benennen
und cis männer für putin unser
vereinswappen ist die russische fahne
mit zwei gekreuzten penissen wir sehen
uns als letzte verteidigungslinie bevor
auch deutschland endgültig zu wo gestern
wird wir sind quasi der weckruf ich sage
nur rock me up before you go go putin
ist einer von uns weil er eben nicht
geändert weil er noch normal ist
orthodoxer christ und böden weiß
die welt zittert vor dem hyper
aggressiven diktator aber eure größte
angst ist dass gender ganz genau frau
moderatorin der ware eiserne vorhang
verläuft nämlich gar nicht zwischen ost
und west sondern zwischen gendern auf
der transporte und echten männern die
karten gehen auf männerclub und zwar im
stehen die frau dr weil hat das letzten
sonntag im bundestag zum glück mal
glasklar angesprochen wer soll uns noch
ernst nehmen wenn wir uns wirtschaftlich
und militärisch das rückgrat brechen und
uns statt mit realen problemen mit
gender gaga und ideologischen
experimenten dort beschäftigen also
statt sich zu schämen für ihre putin
verstehe partei hängt die wahl in einer
historischen rüstungs debatte ernsthaft
vom schlendern an dass so ein
lupenreines ablenkungsmanöver da ist
schon klar dass sie das jetzt hier sagen
im durchgespielten zdf wo in den krimis
jede zweite kommissarin der lesbische
rollstuhlfahrerin aus kamerun sein muss
die ware diktatur ist doch die die mich
zwingt studieren dort zu sagen da gehöre
ich spontan zu den kopf denn bei der
bundeswehr heißt es bald feldwebel und
bootz frau coco ist völliger bullshit
das wurde vor zwei jahren beim bund mal
ganz kurz diskutiert und dann eben nicht
eingeführt lass mir doch von seinem
ehemaligen bettpfannen schwenker nicht
meine ganzen erfundenen argumente
zerschießen und wenn sie mir nicht
glauben hören sie wenigstens auf
deutschlands größten militärhistoriker
bernd hatte
der
landesverteidigung zu einer wurst gegen
multikultur
eingereicht
so nämlich kaputt gegründete armee im
dienste der usa also des internationalen
finanz der banken
aber ist die wahrheit nicht viel
profaner viele rechte sind fans von
putin weil sie sich auch nach einem
autokratischen start sehen in dem einer
das sagen hat natürlich das klischee
wusste jetzt auch noch sein ja die gute
alte nazi keule selbst ein donald trump
nennt putin smart und genial ist ja auch
nazis oder was machen sie einmal nur
genauso weiter welche genau dass dieses
den politischen gegner immer in die
gleiche rechte ecke schieben wird unsere
bewegung am ende nach starker mann und
was der kreis irgendeine bewegung hervor
geht so wer ist die vorsehung
entschuldigung dafür mich denn das
knossalla
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich